hey everyone dork Phoenix released a
trailer showing us what could be the
final x-men movie under the Fox Marvel
banner before it merges with the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but as we look ahead
to this transition which of these x-men
cast members could Kevin Feige keep who
could probably be rebooted and who might
not even survive this movie welcome to
new rockstars news is our deep dive into
all the biggest stories this week soar
also got to talk about venom and DC
birds of prey movie and the Black Widow
movie and other Joker movies that are
happenings spin-off with Harley Quinn
I'm Erik Bosse really me at this table
are Sam bastard Molina welcome back it's
been it's been a minute been one hot
minute I'm excited to be back and I want
to talk about this Dark Phoenix cuz it's
just a lot - there's a lot to unpack and
there's a fun theories out there oh yeah
did you learn a lot of your suspension I
did good I did I'm ready to share with
the class let's dive into it top story
the Dark Phoenix trailer and how it sets
up the upcoming transition of the x-men
into the MCU I already did a full
breakdown of this trailer for all the
interesting Easter eggs that you might
have missed actually they were like
little fun references to the Legion show
on FX and the character Bishop so check
out that video I want us to talk about
the question of which of these x-men
could live on in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe because I think it's pretty
likely that Kevin Feige is going to
reboot the x-men why would he turn down
that chance like this is his baby come
home right and if you think it's it's
huge like the if you think about the
spider-man character and the x-men
character are probably the hottest
properties of the Marvel Comics universe
before iron man came on the scene in the
event of the most popular fictional
character period yeah yeah so much money
it's insane yeah it's crazy um so like
why not create it like that's your face
for right there so of course I assume
he's gonna reboot it now Hugh Jackman
and Patrick Stewart's incarnations of
the characters of course were killed off
and Logan and I think it's possible that
the biggest stars of this x-men timeline
will go to based off this trailer a lot
of the shots suggest that at least one
major character will die which if you
watch the video I was saying that my
theory is mystique but it costs to be
Quicksilver he's not in a lot of the
footage that barely looks like a grave
by the way
hastily dug gravy no it could totally be
like Phoenix like fried someone and
right there just like flowers or it
might be gene cuz Phoenix they're
supposed to rise again anyway so kid at
the school is you want to bury that
quick you don't want anyone to find out
about that dead kid in space get out of
there it can't be that Sara most of if
you know cuz bee sting wearing shoes to
it it's pretty casual Friday
we're toes beat thumbs sounds better
well I'm curious which of these
characters you know we can throw
Deadpool in his supporting players too
because they're part of the x-men
universe as well do you guys think could
carry their own weight as we head into
the MCU and which characters do you
think they're probably worth maybe
taking a new look at and starting fresh
well I know that this is tough because
there at the end of the day I honestly
want them to do that with all of them I
don't I don't want any of the characters
to cross over
aside from Deadpool I think Deadpool is
kind of the given I'm like you know
Deadpool it like would be calling out
the merger right he'd be like I got to
keep my job you know part of it but from
the x-men universe no I think it's time
to start fresh and see what Marvel of
what Kevin Feige specifically would do
with it but if I had to pick cuz you're
making me
then I'll sow this table you're often
squeezed me have deciphered uh
Magneto I think is a fantastic portrayal
and actually really liked it especially
if he's still young in his portrayal of
it so you know he could still even age
into the villain that we're familiar
with but last week I talked about how I
would love to see more mystique Jennifer
Lawrence is not technically part of the
MCU and she's one of the only actors I
kind of like you would assume would be
by now like if they did keep her - that
would make sense I think everybody else
they're kind of like yeah we could do
better casting than this and we're in
better interpretations of these
characters I think better
interpretations they came out steam yeah
I mean I don't have a problem with the
people they pick to play storm and
Nightcrawler and x-men apocalypse but
it's just like they weren't given their
time to shine and they're fascinating
characters more fascinating than what
like Feige said to work with in the MCU
like right ant-man Scott Lang this
little cake air controllers
right the guardians are exactly what
they like had to be able to pull off
because they couldn't do the x-men so
now imagine if they did have those
characters ya know that the guardians
are a great example of like how you can
actually improve a lot of characters
like do you guys remember any
personality from Cyclops from either
iterations that we've had of him
actually we've had like four right
because we had x-men he screams he
screams yeah he's angry and I only hear
yeah yeah you can never get his eyebrows
either right Oh to be fair he did have
those Oakley's instead of I would want
who to bring over I really like these
two like I think I also Jennifer
Lawrence just seems like like done like
I like your theory that like that's
mystique because she's like oh oh I
don't I think is like I how my Indies
yeah looped into this so early on Oscar
yeah so many awards in particular it
would be amazing to see these two actors
like move on but also like they're tired
look at them they look tired last always
hair ya know from stress or any normal
thing from alien Egyptian magic that
doesn't whatever that part made no sense
in that movie anyways but anyone you're
gonna pull over just do the Deadpool
cast it's the one that works the most
and all I also I couldn't tell you who's
playing The Young Ones I couldn't I I
know Tye Tye Sheridan from ready play
when they're all like getting work and
big gigs it's just like they aren't
immediate like franchise holding stars I
would be a real dick move but would be
real fun to watch would be making them
reassuring for their same parts you'll
see my resume I played the role before
like a Greek mythology Cyclops
do a different take on it now I agree
with the Deadpool cast I think they're
all super fun there's a weird thing with
Thanos and cable right like Josh Brolin
I don't know if you could play both
parts maybe they just yeah yeah
it becomes like the Klumps in buffy the
master was played by two different
actors and most people - I've never even
realized it just cuz like once you're
behind all that stuff telling ya it's
it's a shame because I think sophie
turner and anti shared and are really
strong actors it's just like they they
brought them in so late in this
iteration of the x-men universe and
x-men apocalypse in a movie that a lot
of people weren't crazy about so it kind
of trickled down that dis excitement on
to them so now when they're coming back
it's like oh I like sophie Turner in
Game of Thrones I don't know if I'm
ready to see a whole movie where she's
the star of a huge Game of Thrones fan I
don't think Sophie Turner's that amazing
I'm an actress I actually think that
Jean Grey is one of the most fascinating
characters in the Marvel Universe and I
think that Sophie Turner's playing her
not very different than even Sansa Stark
right like she's like basically I'm
playing sophie Turner but could you
imagine like how like chunking that role
is like somebody like Jennifer Lawrence
good a book could really like play the
hell out of these parts I mean this is
like someone who's like essentially has
like trauma and also like supreme power
of the mind like that's just a very
fascinating role yeah it is and it seems
like fox only knows one story that she's
in in this this right that's it like
since this is the third time have we
gotten mention of it also you saw the
Phoenix pop up in the third in
Apocalypse right we had the Anthea which
is super confusing right well I know
there's other these other things yeah
confusing like she visits her when she
first gets her powers as a kid when her
prints in the coma because she
recognized their potential and kind of
lays dormant but it's not full Phoenix
force yet until the space mission that's
but it's not yet I think they had to go
back and kind of retcon that yeah it's
it's used to visit you give 30% myself
to her yeah I do agree I think it's it's
hard to see with light just because I'm
older now when I saw the x-men movies
there was a kid and then throughout my
teenage years when they starting up so
like when I saw Jean Grey and Scott
Summers I'm like look at these adults
who could be my parents and I'm like
look at these children like they did
cast way younger they did cast way
younger but at this point it takes place
in 1992 they're supposed to be around
like a couple years before the age they
are in the first x-men movie
when you know the leather they shot that
97 yeah yeah so it's supposed to be but
it's like I just see the most stupid it
has always looked like 41 like 40 yeah
yeah yeah yeah no I but I I would like a
fresh start with lolis characters and I
would like them to age them up and I
think there's a lot of cool ways that
you could do that there was somebody who
throw out a fun fan theory for like how
you could get the mutants involved I
don't know if you want talk about that
later but worry no but like that the way
that they've introduced that Scarlet
Witch has her abilities there could be a
fun way of her dealing with the trauma
of infinity war thing like instead of no
more mutants you say all of the and then
you but or she's eating out like the
rest of her energy throughout the world
and she becomes like kind of like the
reason why there's more mutants in the
world also a fun way was that if you
have all your Avengers sacrificing
themselves with Infinity Gauntlet blah
blah blah you could have them maybe in
their head thinking like that or wishing
because it's basically the wishing stone
saying that like we want to leave more
people behind for the future to protect
and so it mutants just start popping up
people just start becoming mutants and
that's and there's a cool story that you
could go along with with now that like
the world the MCU hasn't have to dealt
with superheroes in their backyard and
now they're popping up everywhere and
then that's when you get your racist
stories your prejudice and whatnot yeah
I think there's fun stuff you could do
it's very close the idea of infinity
Wars impact creates the mutant gene yeah
Baltar's mutant gene right like him
bringing everyone back there's like a
wave of like some sort of not
necessarily radioactive labor but
something like that that just alters DNA
and you know one in every hundred
thousand people or something I thought
yeah you yeah and you could have a latte
you could have younger older doesn't
matter it's like or you could have a
story that they've been into the whole
time there's a lot of options ECU that's
the one I don't want I don't want
something where they've been there the
whole time because then it's plot holes
like times a million
right yeah they're already kind of
running that with Captain Marvel a
little bit like she was there the whole
time was she really
ya know yet they all are all planted
they're all hang you know we've kept
Marvel on a each planet classic I think
that they'll probably not age them up
unfortunately but I do like those you
know serious interpretations because I
think they're gonna want to do the
school element like the mansion feel and
then also set up for these people
playing these roles for 10 years
hopefully so we'll probably get like a
young version of this being introduced
yeah and it could be kind of cool to
have if you want an MCU connection it
could be really cool to have spider-man
be the connecting piece because you
always have like spider-man Axman like
you said those were your those are the
hot tickets for Marvel in the 90s early
2000s and still yeah in the videogame
where was the spider-man x-men like
there's like a lot of there's a lot of
examples of it working and you could
have like Iron Man being the connecting
piece for spider-man in his movie
spider-man is another connecting piece
for x-men also in the Ultimate Universe
like the popular story was everyone
thought they hated spider-man kind of
because they thought he was an x-men and
also he kind of is right he mutated
because of radiation they're mutants
it's let's just call them what they are
anyways that's a dinner we could do a
whole video on that how you got powers
just call them a mutant because you're
mutated to get them yeah I think it's a
all this just makes me very excited for
phase 4 I know at times we've talked
about like well what's gonna happen
really to the Marvel brand after
Avengers 4 because that's been like all
of it and a lot of these characters I
assume are gonna be moving on like the
idea of Kevin Feige producing x-men
movies under the Marvel brand it's that
that to me is super exciting just
because when I was a kid like the first
comic superheroes that I was aware of
were the x-men those are like the most
exciting stories before we got this
whole idea of cinematic universes the
x-men was more like one of the first big
Supergirl movies we got when we were
kids so this idea of now where it's kind
of coming back home I think there's so
much to explore and sure I'd be
interested in see mystique but I'm kind
of curious to see other x-men take over
just because it's weird how much
Jennifer Lawrence I feel like it's taken
over franchise like mystique is a great
character but there's so many other ones
that they just kind of like bring in for
a movie and then they move on but but
yeah let us know what you think in the
comments below and now I want to move on
to a big announcement in case you guys
haven't heard about it yet new rockstars
is expanding beyond this YouTube channel
to a whole new platform where you can
actually watch us do our thing in
really the best possible format it's
called scenar and for the first time
ever you'll be able to watch something
with us while we break it down like in
real time it just makes more sense that
way so it's a Chrome extension that is
really really easy to add so that when
you stream stuff on your computer you
can open up real-time video commentary
so we can point out all that interesting
details and all that cool stuff that you
might have missed while they come up in
the movie in the TV show that way we're
watching along with you rather than like
awkwardly restructuring and read
formatting and retelling the movie which
is always a challenge for us and scenery
something that you can participate too
so scener lets you give your take on the
shows and movies that you love to watch
by synching your reaction videos
alongside what you're watching in the
same browser so with scener you can
create share and watch video commentary
synchronized with streaming shows movies
and clips from Netflix Hulu and YouTube
just go to senior comm slash new rock
stars on your desktop computer and you
can watch with us and on our new rock
stars channel you can watch my
commentaries on Black Panther and Doctor
Strange you can also see Sam's
commentaries on the CW series the flash
right Sam mm-hmm go check that out as
well but you know stupid answers there
as well but it's very cool and I'd love
to do more because it's such a cool and
easy thing to use cuz you just click and
you go yeah
easy peasy check it out yeah senior it's
time to make a scene check it out guys
it's it's a plugin that you can put on
Chrome and you definitely want to try
this out and let's move on to this
week's a trivia question
the music I assume there's music playing
every time right no no there's never
been been your job to have beautiful
it's just not ready to show the world
yet okay so here's a terrific question
the movie Logan deliberately avoided
specific references to the other x-men
besides the characters in the movie like
Wolverine Charles Xavier Caliban x-23
Donald Pierce Xander rice etc however
one line in the movie mentions one of
the off-screen x-men by name though it
might have been unintentional what x-men
character was referenced in Logan okay
all of our answers are in the blue thing
and later the show reveal the answer a
trivia question closest as the site of
our judges will get to do our sign off
goodbyes at the end of the video
meanwhile the loser will partake in our
new trivia punishments not really new
the latest inductee of the gif of shame
shoes it's behind me I swear I swear
it's back there okay really not so we
got an early look at venom this week and
it's the movies coming out next weekend
but we got a full scene showing Eddie
Brock venom taking out an entire SWAT
team let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's some interesting details to
point out from this you probably heard
that Wilhelm scream when venom through
the officer off the balcony it sound
like again when your voice cracks yeah
they brought in a little prepubescent
boy into a sign just recorded the story
behind it it's an inside joke with sound
editors that they mix into big action
scenes it's pretty much in every movie
like this will home scream in every Star
Wars movie here at like 20 times in
Indiana Jones so you should recognize it
by now to me it's interesting how much
of an effect the SWAT flash grenades
have on venom like they don't knock him
out but they do kind of force him to
stumble a bit and he has to recoil with
his tendrils so like reform so Eddie
isn't like invincible is venom he's just
like stronger than usual
so how old strong do you guys think
venom is it does this action scene is it
what you imagined venom to be and it's
getting more excited for the movie yeah
he's like he's a force of nature it's
not like Spider Man attacking people
it's more of it's brute strength and
it's scary and it's he can it's like
trying to fight like a swarm of bees or
something it's like it's gonna he's
gonna reform in no matter what and like
so even if you hurt part of it it's like
you didn't take it out so I do like that
they showed like he's vulnerable you
gotta show that because then if it's not
then it's like fighting a wall and
that's mooring so it's cool that they
that you get to see that he reacts he it
makes it feel like he's an actual
character in the scene for how strong he
is I feel like we're gonna seem like
lifts up a car or something and use it
as a weapon or something I feel like
that's which is pretty typical of I mean
it was always really like like Spider
Man can lift like a little hatchback or
whatever and then I'm gonna lift like a
truck yeah like that's around where they
were mmm yeah I'm liking this action I
think the design of it of him like
picking up the SWAT guy and using to
like hammer other people is super fun
and like that shows like some good like
stunt choreography and some conception
of interesting action yeah it's a very
creative sequence which is very exciting
because that's that'd be the huge waste
of it right if it was just constantly
like like mr. fantastic style fighting
right but it is very much this like
amorphous stretchiness but I keep
thinking of Candyman they somebody said
fighting the swarm of bees but but yeah
like he so it is very creative that's
the thing that I was hoping for it did
make me more excited to see it which is
good because I wasn't that excited but
the only thing I'm like okay get primed
that get ready on that is his shiny
gloss it does read a hair is like
animated or something in that in that
sequence at least so I think I'm just
gonna kind of like get over that because
it's like you know it famously like
right Legolas or something it looks like
an animated character when he's jumping
off the the elephant trunk whatever a
spider-man famously in various movies
has always looked like he's made of
jelly well that I'm kind of is is shiny
so he does have that CGI cloth so it is
gonna be a little bit of a disconnect
but hopefully I can get over that ya
know same and also that's kind of how I
imagined him though so like that's
there's no way to really get around it
the only way would be if he was more of
like light absorbing instead of so
reflective mmm just like it just a deep
black more like coming maybe like spawn
yeah I can't get over how much I like
the the way the venom said like devours
his head you know it looks like it's
consuming him both like metaphorically
and literally and yeah I didn't know if
it was just gonna be that one time that
we saw on the trailer but it looks like
every time he suits up it kind of comes
over like a mask that he's wearing which
gives it a more like tectal feel to it
rather than just like emerging over his
face and some other weird way or going
down this way no spores yeah and I like
to see that he kind of gets up in the
air a little bit like he's bigger now
he's more imposing also I forgot that
Tom Hardy he's not the short man but
he's shorter than you think and so like
once he becomes more imposing now as
venom and it's cool that you get to see
that kind of transformation its little -
it's just him raising up a little bit
ooh five seven there you go you can go
on let's move on to another story from
this week an update on the birds of prey
movie so this is the Harley Quinn LED DC
female antihero movie and it's cast mary
elizabeth winstead and a jurnee smollett
bell and now Winstead you know her from
10 Cloverfield Lane it's got Pilgrim vs.
the world has been a bunch of stuff
should we play in Huntress Helena Helena
Bertinelli
who
movie will be a former mafia princess
whose family was killed in a mob hit and
turned her into a vigilante wear a smile
at Belle who has been on TV shows like
Friday Night Lights and underground and
True Blood and she'll be playing Black
Canary
aka Dinah Lance or Dino Lance a young
street fighter from the DC Comics so
along with Margot Robbie is Harley Quinn
joining this group will be Renee Montoya
they haven't cast it yet she's a lesbian
detective in the Gotham City Police and
it sounds like they have Justina Machado
and consideration for the role along
with Roberta kalindra and they're both
kind of in the running for it there
might be someone else we don't know yet
but they have narrowed it down and this
one will take on the Batman villain
black mask with the help of Cassandra
Cain and they're shooting the movie in
2019 they're gonna release it
February 2020 so it sounds like this is
a this is great and this is sounds like
this is exactly the direction I would
want the DC Universe to go just like
taking one character and building out a
small thing out of it it sounds like a
very interesting mission that they're
going on in that nice rescue mission I
liked Mary Elizabeth Winstead scrote
about it because it was just like it was
super simple it was just so
straightforward it was nothing nothing
attached to it's just like Cathy and the
director was just like as she pitched
the character so well she was like oh I
get it like I get what you want to do
with this character which that's a good
that's a good sign of a good writer so
like and that's what you hope for every
movie but I enjoyed the way that it like
she's not like excited to play Huntress
she's excited to be this character in
this movie the Cathy Ann wants to make
and that makes me more excited also
Cassandra Cain is such a cool character
and I would love to see more of her and
Renee Montoya as just a detective if
that's what you want or to make her the
question if you want to do that as well
cuz the questions always a fun character
it's a conspiracy theorist but is
willing to get off of their computer and
actually go out and like fight people
which is great and black mask is always
confusing to me because some people are
like oh it's a leather number on his
face it's like oh no it's someone last
night tweeted me it was like no it's the
coffin the wood coffin that his father
died and I was like wait that mean it's
it's war it's a Bini type into a skull
it's so confusing cuz it's like oh
whatever but I and they throughout like
Ewan McGregor's name for that or shelter
comment like there's a couple like
there's some cool names attached to this
that make me excited and I
they have had a crush on mer elizabeth
winstead since I was like super young
and so like this is as cool and journey
seems fun so go for Black Canary that's
awesome and the racist people you can go
ahead and shut up yeah yeah this seems
like a very like exciting direction to
go with it I like hearing that I just
want to play the character rather than
rather than having to like live up to
the expectation of what's in fans minds
and I think having some of these smaller
characters allows them to just kind of
create the character and as it's needed
for the story as opposed to having to do
too much fanservice so that's what this
movie looks like it's just centered on
one specific mission and the characters
serve the purpose for that mission
rather than having to like set up a
franchise or something like that
and I think there's been like seven to
eight different versions of Black Canary
in the arrow shows in Smallville and in
animated form so but there's the one
that they always like like that's the
first girl we always got to bring in you
had Smallville you had Sarah Lance you
had Laurel Lance you had Dinah Drake
then you had black siren then you had a
Nazi version of black siren showing up
that's just arrow over there that's five
different ones for arrow so I think
journeys gonna be fine so sheesh yeah
moving on another synopsis that we heard
about this week was the upcoming Black
Widow solo movie star in force Scarlett
Johansson is Natasha Romanov and it's
gonna be directed by Kate Shortland now
this report came from a fairly reputable
production tracking site it's not
confirmed by Marvel but like these are
people with inside sources and sounds
fairly plausible and here's what the
synopsis was quote at Birth the Black
Widow aka Natasha Romanov is given to
the KGB which grooms her to become its
ultimate operative when the USSR breaks
up the government tries to kill her as
the action moves to present-day New York
where she is a freelance operative the
standalone film will find Romanov living
in the United States 15 years after the
fall of the Soviet Union which is
interesting cuz if this is true it would
set the timeline of this Black Widow
movie in the year 2006 with of course
flashbacks denied to anyone when the
USSR broke up and this would be two
years before iron man arrived on the
scene now it's 2008 and this would show
a 22 year old
Natasha so my question is with Captain
Marvel set in the 90s in Dark Phoenix at
1992 and Wonder Woman set during World
War 1 in the second movie set in the 80s
why
Studios afraid to set female superhero
movies in the modern day what do they
all have to be period pieces I don't
know there's a really confusing why that
date like that's such a specific date to
do that you get hmm it's it's for each
of them it's like they were here the
whole time I get it might be interesting
especially with like Wonder Woman set in
it in World War one that was she was
like the one woman on the scene on those
battlefronts so like you could make an
interesting statement to create an
interesting image I mean that character
has famously even in the MCU is has
backstory that's very dramatic and they
always tease that right so it's there
something already pre established it
like to go back and revisit also though
if they did set it in present-day I
don't know if you guys have felt this
but every movie that's come out kind of
recently in the MCU where it's just one
of the heroes there's this like if
there's always a threat about it or it's
always a thing they have to respond to
is like why didn't they call the other
Avengers why did they just tape titles
themselves and it's like you know she's
a human they don't want to have you like
thinking like well too bad she's not you
know Thor or Thor weren't here because
he would solve this very quickly I you
want to give her like human struggles in
a pre Avengers world where she's also
not that great at like figuring things
out either
she's obviously like growing a lot as a
character but that's not that's a more
boring time to look at instead of a more
formative time when she's she still
maybe has an accent maybe there's just a
version of her that like is like a
little bit more broken I do like the
idea of also like you know maybe more of
a Jason Bourne rogue kind of feel to
where they're actually being hunted
that didn't really wouldn't work with
like shield having already recruited her
and dated they would just come take care
of her you know yeah also they could be
a signal to where she ends up after the
end of this movie so air of infinity war
2 they were like oh we got we have to
tell before
yeah there's no there's no more after we
cast the Jennifer Lawrence for this
world because yeah it's a cinematic
universe so anytime you try to say
something the present day everyone like
us are making videos about like this
connect to the timeline so you kind of
get around that by setting it before all
the events happen in that dark era of
the 90s
like undoing other like movies right
like they're gonna like redo Fantastic
Four back then yeah yeah and you know
it's always fun to see a period piece
it's weird now that 2006 is considered a
period piece you see what specific lots
of movie references what happened in
2006 rent rent the movie because it's
you can you still do that probably not
into the rant rant yeah
pay your rent guys like some of them my
30s now it's not cool to not pay your
rent you're a jerk anyway okay we got an
update on another movie coming out the
other Joker movie in development this is
a one with Joker and Harley Quinn the
spinoff from Suicide Squad starring
Jared Leto Margot Robbie now the script
is being written by Glenn Ficarra and
John Requa they wrote the NBC show this
is us they also wrote the movie Bad
Santa and they said that this Joker
Harley movie kind of feels like a cross
between the two they said that the story
begins with Harley kidnapping dr. Phil
this is just in the script right now and
she wants dr. Phil to help her with her
and the Joker's relationship issues and
the writers hope for a kind of a
relationship movie but with the
sensibility of Bad Santa
kind of like effed up people
relationship between two mentally
deranged people so do you guys think
this is like a step in the right
direction
after Suicide Squad or is this more of
like a Oh we'll see what happens it's
thanks what was that there's a good
tweet out there it was like this is us
and Bad Santa and it was the this is bad
like it's just weird because what why do
we want to see them figure this out it's
an abusive toxic relationship I know
there's times and in relationships when
it gets tough the Joker is but is like
whenever you see the lineup of Batman
villains Joker's in the middle because
you can never sympathize with them and
you're not supposed to right he is like
uber magical Joker funny man terrorists
like you know any he is all embodiment
of evil so it's like seeing them try to
work it out you're like I don't want you
to be there I don't want I wouldn't want
anyone in that relationship so it's like
funny idea funny pitch it's hard to take
to separate out the fact
he brutally murders and tortures and
probably isn't great in other arenas to
her you know like so I don't think this
is a good idea well unless you steer
directly into it and let's that's
something she's like having an active
cognitive conversation about like this
guy I was a normal person working in a
you know an Arkham Asylum and this guy
brainwashed me and she's like aware of
that so she's able to like play that
character at the top of her intelligence
rather than someone who's like you know
basically in Stockholm Syndrome and
doesn't realize I mean are you are you
in that movie she would have to come out
on top of him and like defeat him like
enough right like they're just gonna
like like that's the anger whatever like
you did this to me you know I'm getting
you back I don't want this movie made I
don't want to see this movie I want I
want there to be less Joker movies I
want there to be a good Batman again
like I just I'm so tired of over over
like it's like the shark from Jaws
remember was like such a good character
when you didn't see him that much and
then he became 3d and they put him in
SeaWorld isn't like I really overdid it
it's like man the Joker is a great
character and you guys are really
finding ways to make me like him less
yeah it does feel like they're taking
this the see plot from Suicide Squad and
just trying to make it a ton because
they they did have that kind of romantic
element Suicide Squad and every time was
on scream like why is this what do you
remember that that that they had to
re-edit their relationship in Suicide
Squad and it was like extremely
offensive and then people were like this
we do not like seeing this level of
abuse on screen so they recut it so that
it was like a fun take on it whatever
but they had like take out these
horrible moments yeah and it's like it's
cuz it the more you get into a
relationship the worse it is yeah
because you should never want that ever
you shouldn't want this relationship any
hot topic fan out there I know what
you're thinking you're a look they
aesthetically they look cool but they're
bad they're bad for each other I think
there's room in the world to make a
movie about two mantastic relationships
and abusive relationships I don't know
if this is the lens I want to look at
that through though you know there's a
real conversation is real interesting
compelling characters and storytelling
you can do with that topic I'm not
saying you can never make a movie that
deals
that I'm just not feeling like this
one's gonna do it it feels like they're
doing a comedic take on it I think that
people are writing or super talented
writers I just don't know if it can be
done you know that's the beginning
sounds like the beginning of a bad
graphic novel you ever like turns at
first pages and they had like celebrity
cameos in a Grammy know or something
just like no no no thank you no and this
that's what I say this movies no thank
you I don't I don't want to any you know
what you're right they should be able to
tell these movies it's just if if all of
this could calm down for a second just
all the DC stuff calm down and take your
time and eventually you could get to a
place where you could tell the story and
we would respect it and be excited for
you to actually do this but I don't
trust you so PC not only does it seem
frantic it also feels like like the
left-hander than talking to the right
yeah I mean we're just like oh you're
also working our jerker movie
oh no way I'll tell ya that other joke a
movie the Todd Phillips why give you
next one I keep getting more and more
excited about I'm excited one thing
except for either they're Joaquin
Phoenix's take looks pretty interesting
you're excited about a movie do you meet
immediately wish it was another movie
starring the same character that's also
coming out soon yeah I like it's like
like I agree that like there's something
interesting at that movie but that
doesn't mean that the character needs to
have eight takes on it at the same time
yeah especially with like a superhero
adaptation or a super villain adaptation
my take is always like man I wish they
had just told a story that didn't have
some kind of IP attached to it why
didn't they just tell story about a
struggling comedian in the 80s who
wasn't the Joker snapped and became like
a killer that's a fascinating story like
I don't need to know it's the Joker to
go pay to go see that I feel like
there's they know what we're saying
right these people are mildly smart
right like they they they get it right
there we're doing so much of this part
of me things it could be strategic to
just wash away the Heath Ledger thing we
were just like it was a that was a big
question I can anyone play The Joker
after Heath Ledger is that allowed can
anyone do that again and so it's like
how about we just have like eight people
play it you know four year span yeah and
then
you know now no one even remembers he's
like on TV in movies right Gotham and
everyone in place everyone can play a
joker because everyone has played the
Joker now yeah yeah well let us know
what you think in the comments below but
now comes the time for our New York's
there's news lightening you gets me this
question they're gonna fire them at San
Philip and back at me and we all got
answers quickly without hesitation as
possible are we ready yes yes yes Sam at
Peyton Parker 34 wants to know which
superhero do you think would swipe right
for you on tinder
ah so who is a crush on Sam oh that's a
probably maybe it's not element girl
it's the one girl she can't talk she
only talked to herself and her car looks
like bubble gum that's probably that's
hey you know what she could be a blast
but she turns into water and sand and
stuff it would be a tough relationship
but there's my honest answer yeah there
you go thank you everybody at zak-man 87
wants to know tech man who do you want
to be the most beloved as much as Jon
Snow or be as heroic as Iron Man Iron
Man was in that love they did mutiny and
murder yeah do that many people hate
Iron Man it's like I guess he's not he's
more known as I guess be more heroic
than like beloved by everyone cuz it's
kind of like do we not love our heroes
Iron Man age of Ultron iron.most picking
fights with everyone and then they were
so mad about in a group but a friend
group she shoved his dead son's picture
on his chest he's not that like oh that
scene now yeah
a little weird no I I made a thousand
times over and can I have his money
fair enough and then people keep asking
you a similar one of that yeah these are
all these are repeats alright how about
we'll go it at Andrea Clark ninety-two
Eric what is fan OSes favorite Disney /
Pixar movie of all time fan s's favorite
lady okay ciao
his favorite would probably be cars -
yeah the spine weird death happens and
then Doc Hudson just vanished
quick quick shout out to your car pics
our video Oh find our take up like the
rules of cars it's like we did the whole
thing I'm like do they have sex
vollis ISM exists yeah eleven they have
to take off their car shoes at the
airport that's why we have to do it who
did it the cars go on a plane - are they
sentient themselves who is a radicalized
Muslim in this case yeah return to the
or no actually let's do our 15-second
shoutout alright this is where all of us
gets to a shout-out or plug or ramble or
rant about anything we want Sam you got
something yes okay - I'll do them really
quick American vandals season - it's on
Netflix American mantle does not get
enough love it's an amazing comedy /
true crime show and it's very short it's
eight episodes twenty minutes thirty
minutes apiece you love it also October
19th
same release day as daredevil season 3
go watch the night comes for us or yet
the night comes for us on that
if you like kung-fu action movies that
are just gritty and just balls to the
wall it's such a fun movie get all your
friends together and watch it I highly
recommend it great
oh yeah I'm gonna seed my 15-second
stare across cuz I know he has a bigger
one so yeah I bet shutting us out every
week but it's infinity fan it's it's my
live parody show of like Marvel and Star
Wars and all the stuff that you could
possibly a fan of but it's an
interesting deeper top of your
intelligence take on it it's not just
fanservice and pandering there's a lot
of that but this is an educational
process of the ways that we should look
at these movies and be maybe grateful
for their existence but there's also
plenty of parody of the movies
themselves
I'm excited I've never really worked as
hard on like a comedic project a live
thing that I've done before here in LA
this is actually Philip nice to do a lot
of these kind of things in college
together so it feels like kind of going
back in time a bit and putting on these
big stunts type shows so it's been
really fun but yeah if you live in the
LA area check it out and who knows like
if it's a big hit we might do multiple
showings Evan we might take it on the
road real quick give us one don't right
now be a non-sequitur sentence from that
show that they'll have to come see in
order to understand what the hell that
sentence means a character in the show
says most of my farts have twist endings
[Laughter]
thank you for that and now let us return
to this week's a trivia question that we
asked earlier nothing oh yeah I think we
got it so the way this is gonna work
understood this question oh let's swap
here so as we know the loser of this
will have to be part of the gift of
shame and the way this works is you know
we'll have to draw a random thing from
the box and they have to do it on repeat
and we'll turn it into a gif to make it
look stupid but so just to remind you
what the question was it
was this whole idea of what character
what x-men character was referenced in
Logan a movie that barely referenced
anything in the x-men universe other
than the characters were in it they did
maybe unintentionally reference a
x-men's character's name that some
people construed as a reference so who
was that character definitely not mine I
have Eric I have rogue I feel like row
row broke would be my guy
fimo says storm and Sam said that
comment colloquialism Jean Grey Oh robot
hand man was like we're looking for
Wolverine and they're like Sam you
weren't too far off the answer is
Phoenix so the line was Pierce's I heard
he was in Phoenix
ok so probably not intentional by the
screenwriter there but you know most
Easter eggs that we talk about are not
into the private by the writers the
directors so judges who was the closest
yes yeah
great person between storm and roses and
rogue with onyx both of them right for
it alright so Philip is our loser and
going to have to join the gift of shame
Sam will get your goodbyes yeah I'm oh
[ __ ] will chant Shane and Phil Ochs the
shoebox of shame here all right let's
see pretend you are a bag of microwave
popcorn gradually expanding as the
kernels pop okay great so Phil if you
want to swap with me here are green
screen
yeah and you know guys encourage you to
like use this we have a green screen
here for you now so Philip can like be
anywhere he can be in any awkward study
they want to put him as this he doesn't
even have to be a bag of popcorn he can
be whatever you see him as shame shame
shame shame
look at this interpretation shame shame
shame shame shame is a lifted to
infinity shame shame shame shame shame
this week's episode of new rockstars
news I want to thank our hosts me that's
Sam basher air across a TA Voss and
Phillip Molina at fimo thank you guys
make sure you comment down below
tweet at new rock stars like this video
share it and subscribe for more deep
dives into the stuff that you love
my friends see you next week bye-bye
eat popcorn I'm getting a little hungry
yeah yay cool rowned
oh she's got an accident